could we invite you to lay out the moral
position of the right since we've had
the left no but you are right moral
position is that morality is for
individuals but I do think that it's
getting very hard in a society with an
increasingly strong interfering state a
state which in my view intervenes very
much on behalf of of Commerce and
business to make people's lives more and
more subject to the needs of business
and who's cynical alliance with what I
think is now fourth stage feminism is
really all about getting as many women
into the workplace as cheap compliant
wage slaves as it could possibly manage
I think this particular cynical Alliance
has done enormous damage to personal and
private life in our country I think that
the basis of freedom in any country is
private life and I think the basis of
private life is strong families and I
think that both Commerce and the state
dislike strong families intensely and
want to get rid of them and so we see
this desert of of zero as contracts and
and low wage jobs in which nobody can
afford what would what a normal British
working-class family of the 1950s 60s
and 70s would have seen as normal a one
income being enough to live on so we all
have to go out and slave for next to
nothing
for global corporations and this somehow
has come into alliance with with a cause
which considers itself to be feminist I
do not disagree with anything in
anything at all in Virginia Wolf's a
Room of One's Own I think it's an
absolutely perfect statement of the
feminist case I don't think that
feminism was ever about the destruction
of family life or the regimental of
women into wage slavery as it has become
and I think interested in in the in the
in the welfare of women it wouldn't go
down this road surely you have made the
case against the politics of interest
rather than a politics morality you
haven't you just made the case against a
politics which is defined by interest
rather than with immoral also I'm saying
that
see which which presents itself as moral
is in fact it is in fact a policy of
commercial interest and the pursuit of
power which is so and very often the
case and this is the this is what
idealist politics is about it presents
hard commercial and political interests
as a moral case and people are fooled by
it and then they find afterwards that
they were full
you